hey everyone
did you know that global cyber crime
expenses are expected to increase by 15
each year over the next three years
reaching 10.5 trillion usd annually by
2025.
this is the largest transfer of economic
wealth in history endangering incentives
for innovation and investment and
dwarfing the harm caused by any natural
disaster in a year
these statistics are enough to light a
flame to be aware of cyber crime and how
it can be prevented
so considering this situation simply
learn has brought you a new skill of
course on introduction to cyber crime
cyber crime is relatively new type of
crime in the world any criminal behavior
that takes place on or over the medium
of computers
the internet or any technology
recognized by the iit act is described
as cyber
crime this skill of course is entitled
to upscale your knowledge in cyber crime
and help you understand the ways to
prevent it
so now you must be wondering what is
this skill up course about
so let me give you a quick overview of
what you are going to explore in this
course
first you will come across the
explanation of cyber crime and how it
affects our lives on a daily basis
second you will learn about the types of
cyber crime and how they function in
different situations
and third you will learn how to prevent
these cyber crimes and be aware of them
now here comes the best part of the
skill of course
let me tell you this course has no
prerequisites therefore anyone can take
advantage of this amazing course
this course comprises two hours of
self-paced video lessons created by
mentors with vast experience in the
field they are aware of the needs of
different learners and have designed the
course to be easy to learn apart from
this this skill up course will give you
free access to its self-paced lessons
for 90 days this means you can access
its lessons anytime you want
all you need to do is log into
simplylearn.com and register for the
introduction to cybercrime skillup
course
now there you go now you can have all
the knowledge of cybercrime and ways to
prevent it
get certified with simply learn today
and boost your resume
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here